the senate is scheduled to vote today on
a bill to counter the recent spike in
hate incidents against asian americans
an issue that many asian-american
parents are now discussing with their
own children
elaine keano spoke to two parents who
were having those conversations
democratic congressman andy kim of new
jersey and jane park a seattle mother
whose video of her family's discussion
went viral elaine good morning to you
what did they tell you
good morning to you gail well these
parents tell me that they have talked to
their children about race before
especially after taking them to black
lives matter
black lives matter protests but the
conversations haven't really focused
on anti-asian hate until now
as a father to two young boys u.s
congressman andy kim
finds himself reflecting on the first
time he was targeted for being
korean-american
he was about six when a group of older
kids
mocked his appearance saying things like
how can i see through
you know these slanty eyes and oh he's
he's chinese or japanese oh it doesn't
matter it's honestly one of the earliest
memories that i can remember at all in
my life
what was the feeling you had then i felt
like
i was invisible i was just a joke to
them he never told his parents
but decades later his son austin who's
five
shared his own experience he said a
bigger kid
kept calling china boy chinese boy over
and over again
and my son just kind of laughed it off
it was just like i kept telling him i'm
a new jersey boy
and it was so sweet that he said that
and i could tell it bothered him
what did you say in that moment and i
told him that he did the right thing
at that point i was really floundering
and i really struggled to
figure out the right words to say you
know what should i do
in preparing myself to have this
conversation with my kid
young children now are wondering am i
safe and is my family safe developmental
psychologist tiffany yip
says parents of all backgrounds should
start the conversation
early i think it's really important for
us to think about how we
could teach our kids to speak up
for their peers i think if we can
empower our children to speak up more
for each other
they'll also learn to speak up for
themselves better why would we call hate
a virus
because virus isn't infected it's an
approach jane park is using in seattle
with her two children
basis and
is that somebody is that if somebody
looks different they say
that they're like not as good as the
other
park's conversation came in the wake of
the georgia shootings that killed eight
people
including six women of asian descent her
video talking to bennett about it
has been viewed over 2 million times and
we talked about recent acts of violence
against asian americans
and how did that make you feel sad
because they killed people
yeah what was that like for you to have
to have that conversation with your son
i was saddened because he's so young
it's just the reality that so many aapi
families are facing is that this is no
longer a conversation that we can
kind of table for a later time but park
wants to prepare her children to respond
to all hate
no matter who the target if you were on
the playground and you saw somebody else
and they were being bullied just because
of how they look
what would you do i would say
that's not right and you should be
better not too fast back in new jersey
congressman kim is going through his own
personal reckoning
he's just now learning about years of
discrimination his parents endured
quietly
as immigrants the question for us and
our generation is
are we going to accept that there's just
a certain baseline
of foreignness and xenophobia
and discrimination that we just have to
accept and
i say no this is a moment where
many of us feel empowered to say that
this is just not right
yes we belong
now psychologists tell us that children
are able to understand the concept of
race as soon as age
three and that's why they say it's so
important for parents to have these
conversations early
so the children aren't left to try to
make sense of things on their own
psychologist tiffany yipp says that one
place to start
is to talk about how bias makes us feel
and tony that can open the door for kids
to discuss their own feelings
yeah for a long time the recommendation
was not to talk about it to be somehow
colorblind but now talking about it is
is the best way forward elaine thank you
very much it's quite an ideology
people used to think colorblind is the
way to go but it's not i don't think so
either i like the word color brave
and i think it's good that they're
having discussions with the with their
young children andy kim is right
it is not right and i loved jane parks
conversation with her son
yeah well you see how much comes out in
the conversations and how much yes
how much these kids feel this yes yeah
they're ready for the conversation they
are
as the congressman put it he had to make
himself ready yeah but andy's son saying
no i'm a new jersey boy
yeah right and he is and he is
absolutely is